as more information slowly leaks out
about the new Babylon 5 animated movie I
can finally tell you a few little bits
of information I had shared with me
nearly six months ago welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so it's just before Christmas a sauce
and I speak to quite a bit that actually
works in marketing mostly actually
leaked this information to me that there
was going to be a Babylon 5 animated
movie now I couldn't actually tell you
at that point anything I was pretty much
sworn to secrecy and really there's only
quite a small number of people that knew
this project was happening also I don't
want JMS to get angry at me so I decided
I was going to leave this alone also you
know I need sources to trust me so at
the end of the day if a source says you
can't share this I can't share it now
that the source has told me that I can
tell you what we discussed I'm going to
be onto telling you a few little bits of
information including what the budget of
this movie is going to be how and when
it will be released and hopefully a
little bit of information about how it
might actually be linked to the
reimagined Live Action Project the JMS
is also planning so finally Warner
Brothers announced the road home The
Babylon 5 animated movie we've been
quite excited about over the last week
so thanks to The Hollywood Reporter we
do know a few details about what this
movie is going to actually be it's going
to be set through multiple timelines and
multiple realities John Sheridan is
going to be finding his way through
those realities to find his way home but
before I tell you how I think this is
going to be linked to the now reimagined
live action Babylon 5 Series where
hoping to get as soon as the writer's
strike is resolved I want to tell you
about how this is going to be released
apparently this will be released on a
special edition Blu-ray it will also be
released on those streaming services you
get you know like direct pay download
ones here in the UK it'll be through
Amazon
um and sky but basically you pay to rent
or buy a digital copy of the video I
don't know who supplies that sort of
deal in the United States but I'm sure
you guys will get in the comments and
tell me
um I know HBO have one um potential
service that I can go through and then
eventually assuming based on how sales
go it will end up on a streaming
platform probably Max but as far as I'm
aware that hasn't actually been decided
just yet that will very much relate on
how well the actual movie does through
these other mediums I can also tell you
that the budget is going to be somewhere
in a region of three million to 4
million dollars now this is what I was
told uh as I say before Christmas my
understanding is that the project wasn't
actually complete at that point or it
was still going through editing and Etc
so that is a little bit vague but three
to four million dollars is roughly
kind of the ballpark that Warner
Brothers pay for other projects so the
DC Batman animated movies do tend to
come in more about five to six million
dollar budget but three to four is more
than enough for a project of this nature
to do something really exciting with so
six seven months ago I was actually told
that this animated project was going to
be a bridge between the Babylon 5
original series and this new reimagined
series The JMS is putting together now
it doesn't seem that's going to be quite
true but it's kind of so I was actually
told that it was going to be a direct
Bridge as I said so something that would
lead from Babylon 5 into this new
project now I discussed this with the
source at the time and I said well it's
going to have to be multiple timelines
or multiple realities or something then
a character from The say classic Babylon
um period is going to have to travel
into this new Mirror Universe now I very
much made the comparisons between Star
Trek there I mean the mirroring universe
or some of those other sort of
Dimensions um in Stargate as well we're
seeing that through
um certain episodes where we've seen
that multiple dimensions and multiple
realities
and that seems that this Babylon 5 movie
is going to be actually a standalone
movie so JMS has talked about this in a
few of his tweets basically saying that
if you are not a massive Babylon 5 fan
you're still going to be able to watch
it and enjoy it but actually there'll be
enough there for the hardcore fans as
well now that's a very sensible way to
do this bring in and excite the fans but
also hopefully introduce Babylon 5 to a
whole new batch of fans
now that says to me though that even
though this might give us hints of where
he's going with the reimagined live
action series and we might even actually
see Snippets of it for example one of
the realities that Sheridan then visits
will probably end up being the reality
we then see in the live action series I
don't think from what JMS has said that
it is this complete Bridge into it like
a two-hour advert for the then live
action series I don't think that's what
JMS has planned but it would seem that
actually this multiple realities and
multiple Dimensions storyline that JMS
again has mentioned in his tweets would
give you a perfect window into the
reimagined project now some people are
very nervous about this idea of a
reimagined Babylon 5 and I have to admit
I don't blame them I can't really tell
you when this type of thing when a show
has been rebooted has has ever been
successful
but I'm not sure I can ever tell you
when it's ever been done by the original
Creator either I can't think of any off
the top of my head so for the original
Creator to get another chance and what
he has said in tweets a couple of times
now is basically that he wants to do
Babylon 5 now with all of his experience
since so if he was doing about 15 now
with a clean slate what would he do
different and that's the way he's
approached it so to me
that's a fascinating idea and a
fascinating project I can I if this was
me if I was JMS I could imagine just
this being you know just like a whole
new world
actually getting a project that you
adore and that you had five brilliant
years with but with modern special
effects modern CGI and a whole world you
know a lifetime almost of experiences
new experiences to draw upon
no I think that's going to be very
exciting
and also anybody that sort of says well
this is going to be woke pile of
nonsense like everything else coming out
of Hollywood at the moment
you have to trust JMS on this one JMS at
the end of the day is the guy that did
the original that we loved so much maybe
he's going to frame it in a new world
fair enough there's probably going to be
bits in there that the people that do
get angry about woke won't like
but at the end of the day JMS used to
push boundaries before and I'm sure he's
going to push him again
I trust JMS to do something here that's
really really exciting finally do I
actually think this is going to be any
good
well
I'm not the biggest fan of what Warner
Brothers has done with DC
but I am a fan of what they've done with
the animated DC Warner Brothers animated
Studios who is producing this movie
has a pretty good history of making some
real brilliant particularly Batman DC
animated movies they tend to be very
high quality they tend to be quite
interesting storylines and they really
do explore lots of different ideas
regarding uh I'm thinking more about
Batman here the different aspects of the
character
they have the skills and the people to
really do something that is of a very
high quality so am I worried about
Warner Brothers Animation Studios doing
Babylon 5.
no I'd be more worried about them doing
the live action series particularly if
JMS wasn't involved but an animated
movie
yeah I think that's going to be very
very cool again this will be for adults
it's not going to be for children it
will be direct to Blu-ray so again I'm
expecting to get loads and loads behind
the scenes stuff and Extras I really do
think this is something that the Babylon
5 series deserves
and with JMS at the helm I have
absolutely no concern so this is going
to be something very very cool
and I will be buying the Blu-ray the
second it hits stores I might even buy
two copies and give one away to you
lovely people
so get into the comments tell me what
you think is this a project you're
excited about does the budget sound
about right to you
does the idea of this at least in some
ways linking to the reimagined live
action series that jms's planning makes
sense
also what are you hoping for when it
comes to this project and what are you
worried about get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos do drop first and that
you can see for a small contribution
each month that really supports the
channel without the adverts
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
foreign foreign
[Music]